one of the 22 people killed in the El
Paso massacre was David Johnson he was
shopping at the Walmart Saturday with
his wife and their nine-year-old
granddaughter when the gunman opened
fire Johnson's daughter Stephanie
Melendez spoke with CBS evening news
anchor and managing editor Norah
O'Donnell Melendez says her father died
shielding her mother and her daughter
from the bullets they were in the
checkout line they were in the checkout
line they were about to buy her
everything and she just said she saw him
go down after he pushed him she didn't
know what he was trying to tell them
that he was trying to tell them
something but that he was just pushing
him sound like something your dad would
do yes a million times yes my mom and my
daughter wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for him and what he did and I couldn't
even imagine my daughter I almost lost
what your dad saved their lives
I feel like I'm gonna wake up and this
isn't happening here we see it
everywhere but we don't expect it to be
here at all you know Melinda says they
had just celebrated her father's 63rd
birthday oh my that's just really hard
to watch the grief and what what people
will do for each other those moments and
you don't know how to process that after
Wow all right